[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 6 novembre
l'actualité c'est bien sûr la crise
sanitaire nous ferons le point avec la
directrice départementale de la rs ile
de france marion sinaly sur la situation
du département face au co vie de 19 à
trappes ou encore un rambouillet la
situation est très tendue avec cette
deuxième vague de contamination
les soignants se sont d'ailleurs
mobilisés à rambouillet et la région ile
de france faisait un point presse ce
matin avec le ce nouveau confinement
elle a annoncé plusieurs nouvelles
mesures pour les cantines le déploiement
du numérique et le dépistage du coït 19
dans les lycées cette semaine
l'actualité c'était aussi la rentrée
scolaire et notamment celles à conflans
sainte honorine au collège du bois dole
deux semaines après l'attentât contre
samuel pâtit mais aussi les tests
antigénique qui sont arrivés en
pharmacie ou encore les élections
présidentielles américaines
le résumé en 78 secondes l'information
du jour c'est évidemment le coc u19 les
yvelines tout comme l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france sont subissent pardon de
plein fouet la deuxième vague
s'il ya 400 go a reçu à ce sujet marion
sinaly directrice départementale
yvelines de la rs d'île de france
alors bon soir marion sinaly merci
d'être avec nous encore d'abord quelle
est la situation précisément et en
chiffres dans les yvelines face au co
vie de 19 alors à hier soir dans les
yvelines
nous étions à 627 patients hospitalisés
au total dont 73 patients en réanimation
ce qui correspond à un taux d'occupation
des lits de réanimation de 85,9 % nous
dénombrions 683 décès en établissement
de santé et 622 de décès en ehpad en
termes d'incidence le taux d'incidence
dans les yvelines dépasse maintenant les
quatre cent soixante cinq pour cent
mille habitants et on a un taux de
positivité à 23%
c'est assez inquiétant également pour
notre département mais pour l'entièreté
de la région de france les taux
d'incidence dans les différentes
tranches d'âge puisque il ya encore
quelques semaines ça concernait les
tranches d'âge les plus jeunes et
maintenant on voit que la dynamique du
virus s'est déployée sur l'ensemble des
tranches d'âge et on a une incidence qui
est particulièrement forte chez les plus
de 65 ans et ces chiffres correspondent
aux services médicaux publics et privés
oui tout à fait tout à fait peut-on dire
aussi que l'on est dans la même
situation au cou printemps dernier dans
les hôpitaux alors non la situation est
même plus compliquée qu'au printemps
dernier parce qu'en réalité au printemps
dernier nous avions totalement des
programmes et le reste des interventions
alors qu'aujourd'hui nous déprogrammant
sur différentes phases
nous avons constitué une doctrine de
réponse de l'offre de soins sur sur ce
rebond épidémique et on avait demandé
aux établissements de santé de pouvoir
travailler par paliers et en fonction de
la circulation du virus de pouvoir
déprogrammée par paliers aujourd'hui le
le fin octobre précisément le directeur
général de la rs ile de france à a
déclenché le palier 3 et a donc demandé
à tous nos établissements de santé
publics et privés d'atteindre l'objectif
de 1775 lits de soins continus disent
ils aujourd'hui donc la fin de la
semaine pour pouvoir absorber l'ensemble
des malades decaux vide qui arrivent il
faut dire que sur ces 1775 l'hydre ea
compte qu'on demande aux établissements
on a il faut ajouter pardon les malades
les autres malades qui qui eux ne
peuvent pas attendre sur d'autres
interventions que locaux vides donc en
fait on est dans une situation qui est
plus dur que la première vague qui est
plus fort parce qu'il ya une pression
sur l'hôpital qui est nettement plus
forte qu'en première vague et à part les
lits supplémentaires est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres moyens justement qui ont été
mises en place par rapport à la première
vague
oui tout à fait alors d'autres moyens on
avait commencé à le faire à la première
vague et là on
relancée c'est ce sont tous les acteurs
libéraux les professionnels de santé de
ville qui travaillent ensemble et avec
l'hôpital donc pour les yvelines on a
des travaux qui qui sont engagées depuis
maintenant plus de trois semaines entre
nos acteurs libéraux et les
professionnels de santé à l'hôpital
public et privé pour travailler sur des
protocoles de prise en charge des
patients qu'aux vide que ce soit en
repérage précoce donc en amont mais
aussi en aval donc pour favoriser des
sorties d'hospitalisation qui soit plus
rapide et qu'on prenne en charge plutôt
les patients qui peuvent l'être 1 à
domicile plutôt qu'à l'hôpital
d'accord le président de la république a
déclaré que nous n'étions pas au point
où il fallait choisir qui va vivre et
qui va mourir entre les patients qu'aux
vide et non qu'ovide est-ce que c'est
désormais le cas dans les hôpitaux dans
les yvelines
non on n'en est pas du tout à ce point
là pas du tout mais c'est vrai que on
est très vigilant qu'on a une grosse
pression particulièrement dans les
yvelines avec des hôpitaux qui sont
sursaturé pour reprendre leur terme mais
il ya un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui sont mis en place qu'à notamment une
régulation régionale des lits
d'hospitalisation mais aussi des lits de
réanimation qui permet en fait aux
hôpitaux des yvelines d'aller prendre en
charge de faire prendre en charge des
patients qu'aux vite qu'ils doivent être
hospitalisés dans d'autres hôpitaux de
la région pour pouvoir leur permettre de
redonner un peu de souffle le temps
qu'on ouvre des lits supplémentaires
ça veut dire aussi que pour qu'on évite
d'arriver à cette situation là il est
nécessaire qu on respecte strictement
les mesures de confinement qui ont été
posées par le gouvernement à titre
personnel mais également à titre
collectif parce qu'il est nécessaire
qu'on puisse casser cette dynamique
épidémique
merci marion sinaly d'avoir été avec
nous et pour prendre justement un
exemple concret l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien situé à trappes est
dans une situation lui très tendue selon
les chiffres communiqués par la
communication de l'établissement le
taux d'occupation des lits en
réanimation est de 100%
cela veut donc dire que les neuf lits
dont dispose l'hôpital sont occupés et
donc qu'il n'ya plus de place
en tout ce sont 15 personnes qui sont
actuellement à l'hôpital à cause du coc
u19
l'établissement a donc dû reporter des
interventions 30% des patients qui
étaient prévus en hospitalisation
complète ont été déprogrammés est
actuellement le centre hospitalier
reporte également 30% de l'activité en
dose copic au centre hospitalier de
rambouillet la situation est également
très complexe jeudi une mobilisation à
l'appel de la cgt et de force ouvrière
fo a rassemblé une cinquantaine de
personnes devant l'établissement
elle dénonce l épuisement du personnel
face à la deuxième vague de covile mais
également une différence de traitement
dans le ségur de la santé pour le
personnel soignant à domicile
183 euros c'est la somme que les
soignants du service de soins infirmiers
à domicile ssiad du centre hospitalier
de rambouillet réclame à l'appel de la
cgt et de force ouvrière
une cinquantaine de personnels s'est
réuni jeudi devant l'hôpital pour
montrer leur mécontentement
cette somme correspond à l'augmentation
que le personnel hospitalier a reçu en
cette fin d'année 2020 dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé seul bémol le ssiad en
a été exclu si nous sommes là
aujourd'hui c'est pour se mobiliser pour
le siad qui a été victime du ségur qui
n'aura pas d'augmentation lui
contrairement à tout le reste de
l'établissement
voilà elle se mobilise chaque jour au
domicile pour maintenir les patients
chez eux
et voilà mes collègues et soignantes ont
et ont dû aller en renfort pendant la
première vague à l'ehpad du centre
hospitalier de rambouillet à l'ehpad
dhabi et là on est on sait bien partis
du centre hospitalier de rambouillet et
là on n'en fait plus partie
une colère d'autant plus importante que
la deuxième vague de kovy 19 et bien là
et que le personnel soignant est une
nouvelle fois mis à contribution
selon la cgt 9 lits sur seize en
réanimation seraient occupés par des
patients qu'aux vide il ya des endroits
où ça devient tellement tendue qu'on ne
peut plus s'arrêter ne serait ce que
pour ceux pour se mobiliser mais c'est
une situation qui est très critique dans
dans l'ensemble des services
hospitaliers indue du département et du
est du pays
à croire que la première vague n'a pas
servi de leçon parce que c'est toujours
aussi chaotique mais avec des personnels
de plus en plus exposés de plus en plus
épuisés et donc forcément des personnels
de plus en plus touché le centre
hospitalier de rambouillet est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres dans les
yvelines au 6 novembre 2020
627 patients sont hospitalisés dont 73
en réanimation
comme pendant le premier confinement les
collectes de sang sont autorisées elles
sont maintenues et les maisons du don
sont ouverts durant toute la période de
ce deuxième confinement pour plus de
facilité et pour respecter les
contraintes sanitaires
les dons du sang se déroule sur rendez
vous pour s'inscrire même à la dernière
minute précise l'établissement français
du sang
c'est sur leur site internet ou
l'application don du sang pour donner
votre sang il vous suffira d'avoir sur
vous l'attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire sur laquelle vous coucherez
la 4e case assistance aux personnes
vulnérables et plus de 3500 élèves et
1000 personnels ont été testés positifs
dans l'éducation nationale en france
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer dans
les yvelines
aucun établissement secondaire est
actuellement fermée mais valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france a annoncé ce vendredi plusieurs
mesures pour aider des lycées à
affronter cette deuxième vague de kobe
de 19
les précisions d'astrid bergère des
mesures supplémentaires pour les lycées
franciliens
valérie pécresse a proposé des
aménagements possibles pour les cantines
si le lycée reste en rouge complète
nous proposons des demies jauge adapté
pour les cantines avec la possibilité de
commander pour la moitié des élèves des
paniers repas et de les faire déjeuner
soit dans des classes qui seront ensuite
ultérieurement nettoyées par les agents
de la région soit dans des locaux
temporaires des recrutements d'agents
ont eu lieu depuis septembre 240 en
supplément et 200 autres en remplacement
d'agents malades ou qu'à contacter aussi
la région offre la possibilité à chaque
lycée d'avoir recours à l'intérim
autre point important
la poursuite du déploiement du numérique
nous avons décidé en septembre
au vu de la situation qui se dégrade est
de commander 70 mille ordinateurs
supplémentaires
ils seront à destination des élèves de
première et terminale qui n'ont pas
d'équipement personnel
dix mille ordinateurs supplémentaires
ont été commandés pour les élèves de bts
et de classes préparatoires le dépistage
au sein des établissements a aussi été
pensé
on va faire une proposition au lycée de
mise à disposition de cent mille tests
antigénique dans les lycées les lycées
qui le souhaitent c'est bien sûr ces
tests pourront être réalisés par les
infirmières scolaires des tests qui
pourront être faits sur les équipes
enseignantes et les lycéens avec une
autorisation parentale
toujours dans l'éducation dans
l'académie de versailles
elle a également fait le point un point
de situation pardon et les
établissements scolaires ne sont pour
l'instant pas trop touchés seule une
classe tout de même sur les 44 1521 que
l'académie compte est fermé
241 sur un million cent quatre-vingt
mille deux cent dix élèves sont positifs
au col ville ainsi que 55 personnel sur
plus de 100 milles et l'actualité de la
semaine c'est justin brasier qui vous la
résume en 78 secondes
mardi à conflans sainte honorine les
élèves ont fait leur rentrée au collège
du bois d'aulne étaient accueillis par
niveau tout au long de la journée
dix-huit jours après l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit l'émotion était toujours
présente
une minute de silence a été observée en
son hommage en france le port du masque
est devenu obligatoire dès 6 ans des
parents d'élèves ont été prévenus de
cette nouvelle mesure jeudi 29 octobre
plusieurs commune yvelinoise ont décidé
d'aider les familles en fournissant des
masques aux enfants les tests
antigénique sont disponibles en
pharmacie depuis le 2 novembre
objectif désengorger les laboratoires
les pharmaciens ont répondu présents
pour cette nouvelle mission
plus rapide que le pcr le test est
disponible gratuitement et sans rendez
vous en économie la région ile de france
a présenté hier son plan de mobilisation
pour l'emploi
ils élisent à soutenir les sept cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille demandeurs
d'emploi catégorie a de la région elle
proposera notamment dix mille places de
formation en e-learning le télétravail à
nouveau généralisée pour ce deuxième
confinement le gouvernement recommande
d'y avoir recours massivement les
entreprises saint-quentinoise se sont
très vite adaptés et puis les élections
présidentielles américaines ont débuté
mardi 3 novembre l'événement oppose le
candidat républicain donald trump au
démocrate joe biden les américains
yvelinois ont pu voter par
correspondance
les résultats devraient être connus dans
les jours qui viennent
et pour terminer ce set 8 journal
patrice carmouze directeur de
l'information de tv 78 s'est entretenu
avec le philosophe pascal bruckner
ils ont parlé terrorisme et confinement
je rêvais de recevoir pascal reber
pascal les projecteurs bonjour vous êtes
roman si vous êtes essayiste vous êtes
membre de l'académie goncourt aussi et
alors je voulais aborder avec vous
quelques problèmes d'actualité qui sont
essentiellement le confinement et le
terrorisme lors du premier confinement
vous aviez publié un article dans le
figaro dans lequel vous city un autre
pascal blaise qui te dit tout le malheur
des hommes vient d'une seule chose qui
est de ne pas savoir demeurer en repos
dans leur chambre et voulu répondiez pas
tout le malheur des européens c'est
vient justement de ce qu'ils ne doivent
garder la chambre
alors est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que ce deuxième confinement est quand
même un peu différent du premier
à savoir que la sidération a disparu et
qu'on est con c'est presque habitué aux
au virus
on s'est habitué à la posture de
l'enfermement mais je crois qu'il ya
malheureusement une connotation un peu
plus désespérés dans deuxième
confinement parce que n'avons plus
d'espoir d'en sortir
c'est ça qui est terrible toutes les
annonces que font les médecins chaque
soir où le premier minis ou le miz de la
santé nous explique que non seulement ça
va durer au-delà de noël je peux
probablement ça va encore pollué les
premiers mois de 2000 21 est donc sauf
si on trouve un vaccin ou un remède
nous voilà condamnés à garder la chambre
assez longtemps et ça c'est vrai que
c'est très déprimant nous aient
l'impression qu'on peut imposer cette
sorte de vide au fond quelle confinement
très longtemps à des des peuples il ya
peut-être des réactions compliqué il ya
déjà des élections il faut faire un
arbitrage entre la liberté la sécurité
et je remarque qu'il ya beaucoup dans
les médias et notamment dans le showbiz
des fiers-à-bras des matamores il nous
explique que il faut braver l'ordre
public
mais s'il se retrouve demain à l'hôpital
dans des services de réanimation
encombré je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ont
la même bravo au médiatique la bravoure
de plateaux de télévision qui sont
aujourd'hui il faut arriver voilà il
faut arbitrer
que voulons nous et que l'on accepte de
de vivre admis ou à moitié pendant
pendant pratiquement un an avec
l'espérance de retrouver ensuite une
certaine une certaine indépendance
d'azur et de et de mouvement c'est ça
qu'il faut il faut voir arbitrer lors du
premier confinement de la première crise
enfin du virus on avait entendu beaucoup
de gens dorment haut rhin par exemple
dire que le corps d'un virus allait
ouvrir le chemin d'un monde nouveau
on entend beaucoup moins ce discours
aujourd'hui est-ce que d'abord il
n'était pas un peu utopique et est ce
que parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit que la
réalité au fond n'est pas si drôle que
ça que ça ne construit pas un monde
nouveau ce virus mais non c'était ici
beaucoup de gens un peu cafard uni liste
je pensais que nous allions aller vers
la décroissance et que sa lettre
merveilleux qu'on allait sauver la terre
et réduire l'homme à une sorte de
d'animal peu producteurs de gaz à effet
de serre et puis les gens sont rendus
compte que la décroissance et les six il
faut vent table c'est horrible c'est là
c'est la fin de tout ce qui fait le sel
de la vie et que le le montrent de
nouveau c'était le monde d'avant empire
donc les je crois que l'aspiration d'une
majorité de gens aujourd'hui c'est de
revivre comme ils vivaient auparavant
sans obstacle sans barrière de pouvoir
au moins circuler voir les gens qui
l'utilisent m le simple geste de
d'embrasser ses proches de ne recevoir
ses amis ou sa famille est devenu un
geste trop de danger donc un baiser sur
la joue et est en quelque sorte porteurs
de porter de mon potentiel et c'est on
peut pas dire que ça se soit une
nouveauté exaltante non c'est effrayant
comme l'était d'ailleurs toutes les
pandémies dans l'histoire qu'évidemment
on a oublié parce que pour l'instant
notre sol notre secret
son possible à cet astre coronavirus
c'est un geste minimal c'est à dire
c'est le retrait d'isolement loin des
autres alors l'autre actualité c'est
très douloureux aussi c'était évidemment
le terrorisme lorsqu'il ya eu
l'assassinât la décapitation de cette
saison samuel pâtit vous avez vous même
parlé d'un acte de guerre propos car
près d'ailleurs le premier ministre jean
castex mais cette guerre il faut la
mener contre qui contre les crétins qui
passent à l'acte ou contre ceux qui
aiment leurs bras enfin il faut l'amener
à plusieurs niveaux d'abord je pense
qu'à une guerre sécuritaire des services
secrets la dgsi la dgse avec tout leur
arsenal de renseignement et policiers il
ya à garder des guerres de la police et
la gendarmerie
il ya aussi une guerre classique celle
que mène par exemple nos armées dans le
sahel et qu'elle pourrait mener
éventuellement sur d'autres fronts
pyrrhotine guerre culturelle c'est à
dire dénoncé sans relâche tous ceux et
toutes celles qui depuis des années nous
explique que nous au prix vont les
musulmans en france et que donc nous
devons payer pour un racisme structurel
qui s'appellerait d'islamophobie
mais je remarque d'ailleurs avec avec
plaisir que de nombreux intellectuels
musulmans ont réagi récemment notamment
dans le monde à cette dénonciation en
expliquant que les musulmans sont très
heureux en france et qu'on ne peut pas
boycotter la france aux veaux au motif
qu'elle opprimerait cette minorité là et
que celui s'agit là d'une analyse
complètement fausse mais c'est le miz
l'éducation a lui aussi jean michel
blanc coeur dénoncer l'islam au
gauchisme dans les universités et je
crois qu'ils aient eu raison
cela d'ailleurs rejoint le propos que
nous avions antérieurement
je pense que effectivement des groupes
très actifs dans les médias et à
l'université me veulent
détruire la société démocratique de
l'intérieur en accentuant ses défauts et
en les élevant au statut de crime
merci infiniment parce qu'elle votre
peuple vous avez accordé cet entretien
je rappelle le titre de votre dernier
livre qui est chez grasset s'être
coupable presque parfait merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
patrice carmouze c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi même
confiné je vous souhaite un très bon
week end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]